and really the only thing I didn't like
was when they took off his mask and it
was Danny McBride cuz like you know I
know he's trying to get in a horror and
stuff but you know alien Keppel know
just kind of flows no play before there
for the videos
[Music]
hello reject nation it's Greg out here
and I'm John we're gonna talk about the
highly-anticipated
Holloway 2018 40 years later we're
finally getting a sequel can you believe
it guys long way to took a lot to go a
long while they get there listen before
we hop into this review which will
contain spoilers by the way it won't be
a scene-by-scene breakdown I have no
idea what even know things about the
movie yeah so yeah it's not gonna be a
scene-by-scene breakdown we're just
gonna you know have a conversation about
it and I'm sure they'll be spoilers
we'll definitely talk about the finale
and everything like that before we go
into that I want to say thank you to
everyone has been follow us in the
Stardust at people we have passed 7,000
followers over there we do 30-second
reactions for films TV shows and
trailers we also do a lot of micro
sketches and whatnot on that app it's a
lot of fun and there's a lot of big
youtubers on there as well it's free to
use free to download so down the app and
follow us today people anyway onto
Halloween since there's no non-spoiler
review who's gonna get my general
thoughts on this movie when the movie
was done I knew I really enjoyed the
hell out of the film what I came to show
up for it delivered Jamie Lee Curtis
fantastic in this film the best part in
my opinion close to the best and if not
second best Michael Myers he's amazing
in the film he's really good John
Carpenter music also amazing everyone
was really sad about John Carter coming
back to the music and stuff and I was
like no I am guess I'm excited too and I
listened to him I owe
great music especially compared to just
all the installments that have come
since that arrival when you get back to
a carpenter score you're like oh as I
kept thinking about it and then when I
woke up the more I thought about it the
more I realized I really love this movie
I have and I think this is my favorite
one of the franchise I want to make a
disclaimer here I've never been a big
fan of this franchise no not one I know
like this is just the part two - the
first one all the other ones are
discounted whatever I am the kind of guy
who acknowledges that the first movie is
an important film in cinematic history
that's one of those major appreciation
films and not something I particularly
love I've heard quite a bit of mixed
opinions on this review I'm on this
review what you guys were saying about
this
I've read quite a bit of mixed opinions
on what people think about this movie
it's like yeah there's a Rotten Tomatoes
consensus or whatever but in terms of
like the YouTube sphere so many mixed
opinions and I'm on that side of the
fence where I'm like I love this film I
don't know why people are necessarily
disappointed with the movie I can kind
of get why yeah my personal opinion I
love what they did with it what about
you John yeah I really appreciated this
too I mean it's still you know sinking
in it's a big deal to do this kind of
sequel at this point in time for
Halloween and I feel like in a lot of
ways this is kind of where I'm sitting
now what the first movie sort of
deserved I felt like this is kind of one
of the best slasher sequels or best
horror sequels I've seen in a long time
and perhaps ever because it just takes
such a logical approach to what might
have happened so many years later and I
think it also does a good job of
combining what makes the original film
and you know this some of the subsequent
films great some of those aesthetic and
you know content choices but also being
in the minority of Rob Zombie Halloween
fans I thought it also drew from that
aesthetic as well and gave me things
that I appreciated about both sides of
the Halloween coin into one big movie I
appreciate slashers that give all their
characters something to be doing or some
kind of story even if we're only gonna
check in on them for a few minutes
before they die and this movie does that
it's like everyone's a character and you
kind of get where everyone's coming from
in the complication of the situation and
also just the raw nightmare carking back
to that original film watching him stalk
through the neighborhood killing people
like it really took me back but also
forward at the same time yeah I remember
being a little bit conflicted on how I
felt about the kills in this movie
because the kills are never fun in this
film they're not grim in the way how Rob
Zombie's Halloween movies work but still
there's this one scene where before a
woman gets a knife stabbed through the
back of her head and then it comes out
or cheek yeah and every character who
gets a death in this movie they get a
little bit of time to get to know even
this random woman
it's not even a character in the movie
she's on the phone she's talking and
she's clearly dealing with something
yeah and in there you're like oh she's
probably like a trouble mom or something
like that
murder little glimpses literal window to
her life right before she's a good cuz
it doesn't do that thing where it's a
bunch of you know campy kills or
characters there are some characters in
here that I think are a little dumb I
don't like this psychologists character
to be on it's like the main
psychologists guy I'm like you seem like
the worst psychologist I've ever seen I
like the way the guy handled the
performance but I think in terms of
writing the character I wasn't a fan of
a movie that's go over like that
realistic approach like I don't know a
guy who just seemed like very ridiculous
to me that's a fair criticism although
III must say I do like the way they
handled those two characters in context
of the overall plot the way you're kind
of following their thread and then that
thread gets cut short in a really nasty
way yeah I would prefer if the trailers
didn't obviously show us that was gonna
happen although you know the teeth I
thought that was would have been his
teeth so that was nice at least throw me
off moment yeah I mean I I like the way
the gore is handled in this movie
because it escalates it escalates into
like whoa we're getting like [ __ ]
crazy here there's like little teases
here there with like a cool kill here a
cool Kiril there may be like a gory
image like the guy at the gas station is
holding out his jaws like open wide and
I hate that bring in the I don't know if
I should call it realism but those yeah
those gore gags that make things look
that much it's not cool horror movie
gore it's like oh god yeah if you smash
someone's face into a desk that's
probably what it would look like and I
appreciate the kills in this movie too
because again I think they straddle that
line where some of them are very
suspense-filled and some of them are
very gruesome and very visceral and yet
both because like there's that scene we
saw in one of the trailers with the
hammer which takes place all off-camera
and is just as horrifying as kills you
see directly she's the only one who you
don't get a backstory on yeah other than
she's doing garage work and watching her
baby ya know she has a baby until after
and I even like the way that moments
handle because first what's Tiger like
did you kill this baby
yeah which wood is made me like yeah I
don't know about this movie man yeah
what hey I mean his first kill is a kill
which i think is great we didn't make
you hate him they make you really
feeling me and you and then let's you
know right up front like oh this guy
doesn't spare going through the movie
now and I'm like how are the kills man
I've heard some people complain about
the mixtures of tone in here and I had
zero issue with that I thought that when
it was funny it was funny it was
appropriately funny and I enjoyed a
little black kid who they babysit yes
sequence or even the first kid who gets
killed he's like dad I really love honey
with you but I'm really passionate
doesn't seem like what the hell is this
movie I feel like a lot of the
complaints where I hear disappointment
come into this film is because these are
there are a lot of people who are very
much married to the very first Halloween
movie which kind of has this one tone
throughout you know this like ominous
like or tone but this this movie I think
infuses that but then also has like a
mixture of other elements in there that
really packs a punch and I like that
it's very entertaining to me this whole
finale we're gonna save that for later
this whole finale I thought it was very
tense yeah it's been a while since I've
seen a movie where I am that tense
during the finale yeah yeah and it feels
like kind of an authentic mess you like
the first one came out in like the late
70s and of all the Halloween's that one
feels the most like a 70s movie where
you're just kind of watching events
unfold and it's not overly encumbered by
a plot structure like yeah these are now
and I thought they did a good job
bringing it back to that sense of like
oh yeah all of these characters are kind
of involved in the same situation there
are effects all around it does sort of
feel like it's just unfolding naturally
for the most part and that really adds
to every part of the movie yeah and what
leading right up to the finale
barring maybe a couple conveniences or
coincidences you know things that every
horror movie has some of you really get
this yeah
visceral journey of people just trying
to survive and take down this boogeyman
has been looming for so many years and
there are multiple arts tied up in that
also about the characters which is nice
well yeah I mean like Laurie Strode in
this film I loved what they did with her
character so much this is my favorite
Laurie Strode prophetic we've seen the
Rob Zombie version we've seen her
progressed in the whatever like the
second or third time watching this
version of her who's obsessed with like
she's traumatized and she's obsessed
with preparing for the return of Michael
Myers like 40 years later I like this
approach of the destruction that it's
caused her family there's some like very
on-the-nose exposition that I'm like
whatever
honestly all this movie really is is a
fantastically executed slasher movie
like when you break it down I'm like
that's exactly what I wanted and
expected I don't know what this like
it's same caliber of masterpiece cinema
that people are expecting at it is I
mean Halloween is a classic be partly
responsible for all yeah sub-genre it's
important but it's also a slasher
because like the things I cared about
they delivered Laurie Strode I knew I
loved this woman this interpretation
where she shows up at her daughter
because they do some things where she's
like taking on the Michael Myers rover
she's outside of Allison's yeah like
watching her and then she's like at her
school giving her money or something to
build a bunker and learn how to shoot
and then she has that line about you
know if your mother hates me
but Mike's more prepared yeah the
horrors of life yeah yeah right then and
there and then I think I think either
the montage of her shooting stuff is
right after that or it's before I can't
remember there's like something actually
close yeah it was that moment where I
was I just knew I loved this character
man like she is not liked you understand
where she's coming from she's made
choices but she is she sticks by her
choices here but we also it's easier to
get on board with her when you're like
she's gonna prove everyone wrong
there's strain within her family because
her family doesn't quite understand and
there's trauma there but it's like we
evolved seen the horror
that she lives through the first that
her family is about to find out or very
real and not just remnants of the past
yeah and I feel like this is a great
movie for that character cuz like the
original Halloween too is like a sequel
that yeah we can make a sequel let's do
it you know and this feels like the
sequel that that character really
deserves because she gets to add a whole
other dimension to the character it
makes all the sense to me anyway that
you know she might go this way and in a
way again as much as people pants some
of the ideas in Rob Zombie's movies I
feel like this does share a kinship
especially with part two because you do
have that mentality of no no no
surviving this horrible scenario doesn't
make you a superhero it might make you
very traumatized and it might produce
you know a lot of the events of your
life afterwards you know it might cause
you to go down a darker path I think Rob
Zombie's Halloween had this gimmick of
let's explore the psychology behind
Michael Myers and stuff yeah and it
doesn't really commit to it and weirdly
I think this movie does a better job
than that well cuz this movie is not
actually trying to give you an answer
about who Michael is and why cuz part of
the point they brought it back to is
like we really don't know but they still
bother to have the debate around it you
also have characters going is this guy
human or is this guy just a monster that
we should put down I mean they have the
what's the new doctor's name dr. Loomis
part two of whatever left I'll call dr.
Loomis part two there's people who are
constantly trying to understand him and
I like the approach of how he hasn't
talked for forty years and I think
there's some cool visual tricks they did
with Michael Myers because I didn't know
this until this morning but Michael
Myers play about two people here you got
the shape where Michael Myers does not
have a mask you know it's like the guy
still has a scar and if you remember the
first Halloween the one time you see his
face he has some kind of scarring on his
face you never really get a good full-on
image I wonder if like if you go frame
by frame in this movie you have not DVD
to be able to see like in the bathroom
beating scene see like parts yeah Jason
I can you really make him I'm you can
find the guy on IMDB if you want but in
the movie do you see it and then there's
another actor for Michael Myers when
he's just the full-on shape of the
Michael Myers mask and when he's got his
mask off that's the original shape
that's Nick cast so it is yeah that's
cool yeah and the way they handle
Michael Myers I think there's a cool
build-up to this movie because the
trailer
sort of pitch this as Laurie Strode
versus Michael Myers and that's
ultimately what this film is building
towards in the finale and I know some
people have some disagreements about how
the finale is handled but I think the
movie overall does a great job at that
the first half of this movie in terms of
Laurie Strode is everyone saying Laurie
you have to heal and get over it and
then you got you know kind of a similar
setup to what the first Halloween movie
is Michael's main transport is gonna be
incarcerated I like how they have this
moment Jamie Lee Curtis shows up and she
sees Michael and it's not like I'm gonna
do it I'm gonna shoot him if she's
scared yeah so even though she's
prepared for this for 40 years she has
to deal with this trauma she shows up at
her family dinner that she's not really
welcome to and she starts crying it's
kind of embarrassing because the
boyfriend Cameron Cara weirdly I
remember his name but no one else's
maybe but that boyfriend Cameron is
there like a lot of people don't really
care about this as other supporting
characters in this movie I personally
like Alison the granddaughter she was a
character I actually really much enjoyed
maybe because she's the only one who as
this buildup is going it's like Michael
Myers is broken out there trying to keep
the information a little private in the
media that Michael Myers is out on the
loose so it's not like the Strode family
is all going oh my god you're right
you're so right so what is building to
that moment where they're gonna see each
other it's intense
like you keep awaiting that moment and I
like the reveal that mustache Loomis
says about maybe his Drive and this is
what I mean by actually having a kind of
a psychoanalysis of the guy yeah it may
be the drive that keeps him going is
trying to kill Laurie Strode and I
thought that was a neat way to tie it in
because that's not really established in
the beginning of the film but then when
it's revealed and you're looking back at
everything it does kind of make you go
maybe maybe that is it and the movie
doesn't define that and make it 100
percent clear even though he does show
up but he does try to kill her in the
end cuz speaking of that there's a lot
of great moments in here that I thought
were handled really well usually in
these movies baby sitter debts are like
whatever to me when that woman got baby
sitter he gets killed you know that 28
year old playing a high school
everybody is maybe 20 but when she gets
killed I really felt bad for her yeah
that was what happens when you make
these characters characters and you get
to like most babysitter's in horror
movies suck yeah she's actually a good
babysitter yeah got a rapport with the
kid there's a lot of endearing stuff
about that that's really fun and yeah
when she eats it you're kind of
heartbroken about that yeah I mean for
her boyfriend a little bit you know I
like the boyfriend character too because
he had a line early in the movie when
he's saying there are worse things that
have happened this 40 years ago guys in
jail get over you know it's like a
standard yeah because I even have the
thought of movie you know like why is
this such a famous big deal my
girlfriend was telling me of how like
you know a lot of like Charles Manson
didn't kill anyone but he that is such
an infamous thing yeah well it's such a
big story and it's it's a small town
this is the mythos around it it does
make sense why this is such a large tale
in this world that it existed oh yeah
it's taken on legend status you know
especially for a small town like that
you know yeah never leaves you yes been
on Halloween night you know it's just it
already a holiday but I think there's
like plenty of clever sequences to wrap
that you can break down I like the
moment where the one dude they hop the
fence you wanted a girl so bad you just
couldn't have it was like that was a
cheeky not really yeah this movie has is
filled with touches throughout that are
not see the original all the way from
the opening credits I like the way they
did that with the pumpkin kind of rising
yeah like on rotting in Reverse yeah
yeah like that was a cool thing with the
original kind of logos and credits on
there that actually get like even
something so simple as the titles gave
me a bit of a chill yeah when it first
popped up and then you know there's
there's literally nods throughout this
entire movie you can even break even
from little things of what the boyfriend
is before he goes in the motorcycle he
looks at the the clothes line of the
coin yeah yeah there's a famous moment
in Halloween where Glory's looking at
just vanishes out of nowhere she's
watching him there's so many nods from
beginning to end in this film you even
switch Lorien for Michael in like two
scenes I get me yeah yeah some of them
subvert and some of them are just
straight-up references like a they even
work in the little silver shamrock kids
from party yeah we you know as a tribute
like there's I think a lot of stuff for
Halloween fans and for the most part I
feel like any of the nods that are super
obvious get subverted like when she's
sitting in the back of the classroom
looking out the window you're like oh
what if Michael's out there but it's
Laura yeah like that I appreciated that
kind of stuff I never thought the
references got too obnoxious I guess
like my issues that that come in with
this film I like mustache Loomis twist I
was like okay clever movie for a call
item you're the new doctor Loomis I get
it yourself aware cool lady yeah but
then when he kills Hawkins sheriff guys
I thought that was a cool twist because
I'm like oh you're not dr. Loomis Bart -
yeah crazy trying to use Michael to kind
of figure out some weird psychoanalysis
thing by letting he's almost like a
glass he's like I gotta get these two
together so I can see what horrible
thing happened I get what they were
doing with that twist of a guy who just
became so obsessed with this one patient
to try to understand him that he's
willing to do anything to get some kind
of Glinda to get his mind to get it
nothing works yeah so I get that but
there was something about the way that
the scene was handled I liked the idea
of it more than how that scene played
out I thought it was kind of it's a bit
too villainous easy yes
yeah I would have liked a nuance on that
it's kind of a weird thing to complain
about cheese and the Halloween franchise
but that moment was a little too much
for me and how it was under Eddie some
dude with an accent with a mustache you
already look like Loomis but instead of
a goatee you have a must why did he got
killed I mean he gets drived yeah he
really does that's perhaps the most
gruesome like over-the-top kill in the
whole movie - I'm so over it by this
point but if you like to try to dissect
it has the same problem Rob Zombie's
Halloween hat or
the Halloween's [ __ ] this guy like you
own weight lifts the whole time doing
nothing yes evil just making you super
strong you just fueled this guy must be
like 65 big butt is limping around 10
smash this dude's head it's not even
like it was like I get on one hand and I
gripe on the other because I'm like that
doesn't make a whole lot of sense but
for the evil you know it's effective so
it's it's not a perfect it's kind of a
half way for me there's some kills in
here that are very much that like Oh
like the whole bathroom sequence oh yeah
that's sleeper Rob Zombie is like really
grim and really nasty and really
handheld yeah it's really brutal and
then you get some rind house kind of
kills like that yeah look like teeth
he's dropping teeth on the ground or the
head smash it's like wow that's that's
very crazy nice I mean there's a great
supporting cast - I mean you've also got
like I like the family dynamic i like
judy greer or like toby huss as that I
don't like Judy Greer in this movie no
I'm sick of seeing Judy Greer play mom
who disagrees I do have that fun I was
like you are getting tight yeah I don't
but I got what they were doing with her
character and I understood her homework
she's someone who's been through a lot
of trauma evidently been through a lot
of therapy you could hear it in the
dialogue with the types of definitions
she's throwing like oh you've you've
been through a lot of therapy and I get
what you're doing and there's one moment
I really like of her so like a bitchin
moment in the film I didn't believe her
at all like I just did I liked like the
dad's funny but I don't know like the
camera thing you know what I liked about
Cameron he didn't seem like douchebag
boyfriend then he became douchebag
cliche boyfriend I was like why'd you do
that I liked that you he wasn't doing
that yeah
maybe that kind of keeps making better
choice yeah than that
like I think the supporting cast I don't
hate I think they're fine but they were
here to add the movie yeah the movie is
Laurie in my movie shines like crazy
when it's Michael on screen or Laurie on
screen yeah but they really tried like
Judy Greer especially making her or like
Alison I preferred but Judy Greer was
this character I'm like I just don't
quite believe you I don't believe her as
Laurice Rhoads daughter I wanted more to
give weight to that yeah I went with it
because that's what the movie told me
and they had you know enough going on
that I was Jamie Lee Curtis his voice
sounds like a tough woman you know I get
that this Judy Greer has been through
therapy and whatever the way she carries
herself the way her voice is there's no
history of that type of upbringing in
her performance and that's what bothers
me about it Laurie was a normal girl
than traumatized at like 17 years old
yeah
Judy Greer's character has grown up yeah
like you should be like I'm mommy the
chick in the finale though that finale
is one of the most intense sequences
I've experienced in a long time they
stood all the setups really well I don't
know why Jamie Lee Curtis kept all the
guns in one spot catch it like 45 Rob
yes she lives in the house from don't
breathe like you would have made your
job a lot easier if you just had some
guns and other places yeah maybe
oh that whole sequence I really did
appreciate because it had me going I got
angry at the movie haha because I
thought are you to [ __ ] kill Laurie
ya know how he's gonna go yeah it was
so effective like when she's getting her
head bang he reaches through the way the
movie has set up Michael throughout as
this like non-stop serial killer
yeah and that moment comes and the way
how things are juices going you're like
oh my god it's gonna happen isn't it and
that was about to get pissed at the
movie I wasn't gonna be like bold move
wait you kill her and freakin
resurrection and now she just bring her
back and kill her and get like I was
about to go there with that that mom if
we're doing right by Laurie this is not
right
it's so bit like the first time she goes
to showdown with him but no even when
she's like going through the house and
stuff that [ __ ] was like I was I was
ready to get mad at the film for killing
her that's how good the finale was maybe
it wasn't like you know then throwing
fists at each other it's all right the
movie seemed like it was setting up for
her to maybe have some moment of closure
to be like sick is the the psychologist
dude says see the thing you wanted to
say yeah she doesn't nor does she need
to cuz that's not her intention that's
on her motivation so she doesn't need to
when that showdown happens like that nod
of she gets thrown through the window
and then Michael looks over and the one
Judy Greer moment I I loved which I
think everyone loves is when you know
Allison finds her way back good for her
Meghan good thing you ran that direction
though no compass hurt you know when she
has the gun she's like doing the act
that she's terrified yeah got you and
then shoots him you're like I was like
and the Jamie Lee Curtis says happy
Halloween you know treat [ __ ]
right back to crimes but he never ever
rest in peace
I gotta say as cool as it was when
everything was on fire and the clever
trap and three women banding together
who helped take down Michael Myers like
sweet [ __ ] and I loved the shot when the
flames are going on he's in the basement
doing that slope and I'm Michael I
really and I don't know how anyone feels
about it some people might think it's
stupid to get mad about this because
it's Halloween it's
Chai's I hated the way how they ended
this like we gotta end this in a way
where we can get us equal oh yeah the
way they cut back in the room and you
don't see Michael anymore yes or not but
yeah it's like at least show him on fire
so we could have the scene in part two
words like he finds a way to gun fires
just like [ __ ] like they I don't know
what did the hell he does but the fact
that they do that moment like that after
all that build-up and that's what got me
mad about the whole gun thing how many
guns you having which of these scenes
that we get with guns in this movie and
you couldn't wetland one great shot on
the guy take him down in the head you
know you just had a gun planet somewhere
in the kitchen it irritated me that that
was the ending of you got all this
build-up all this set up to take him
down I'm Yatta Yatta Yatta and then you
shoot it in a way where you think you
can trick the audience into thinking and
she killed Michael but like if you pay
attention to the shots she obviously
didn't yeah I mean I guess I took it in
a way at the time where I kind of got a
halfway point with you I was sort of
like are they trying to leave this
ambiguous once they cut back into the
burning room you don't see Michael we
don't know and there's always that like
the whole series runs on this idea of we
killed him oh wait we did yeah I guess I
don't mind having the inkling there
because that's part of Halloween to me
that being said I hope they don't make a
sequel to this I'm going to I don't want
that I think it's already green the
thing is that like that's weird to me
because it seems like the whole point
about this movie is to come back and go
we did it right and was it right by
Laurie and we closed the book yeah and
and this is what why we waited all this
time to tell the actual sequel and the
true story of what we intended for
Michael not quote me on a time where you
can make a movie like this with that
kind of vibe underneath it and then go
will this made money let's do another
hallway yeah yeah yeah and I really
don't want that I'm okay with that
ending if they don't make a they do I'm
gonna be like oh dude look because then
it's gonna make this movie suffer a
little bit in my eyes absolutely and
that
that was my exact issue with it sum it
up it's so obvious what they were doing
with that ending let's and in a way
we're like we can end it they die if we
put a flute but if we want to make a
sequel we can because yeah that's my
issue with with that ending its reasons
yeah it's like the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre it's just there in the back of
a truck we did it yeah the end which I
don't know is another one of those kind
of seventies esque things where it's
just like oh yeah what are we gonna do
go to a diner and have a nice meal and
laugh about the experience but for me I
would give this like a solid 4.5 out of
5 stars
yeah and I mean especially for what it
achieves and for how much finesse it has
like yeah there are things that could
have been a little better written or a
little better fleshed out you know or
better conceived overall but for the
most part I this is one of the best
slash for sequels I've ever seen yeah
it's pretty uh it's pretty awesome stuff
alright guys well what did you think of
Halloween 2018 people leave your
comments down below you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell to get notified
every time one of our bids is up and
check us out on Stardust app free to use
so do free things see ya